So I've been working on some new horror stories
for you guys that I'll be uploading here on
the channel very soon, but the one I'm working
on right isn't quite done yet, so I don't
really have a video for this week.
So I figured what I'd do is do what every
YouTuber with over 100,000 subscribers does
and get my assistant to do it for me.
Introduce yourself.
I'm your Google Assistant.
I can tell you jokes, riddles or random facts.
What about horror stories?
Here's what I found.
Write me a horror story.
Have you ever heard the urban legend about
the assistant that wouldn't help?
The story goes that there was this couple,
and they were at home.
They wanted to see a movie at 9, so they asked
their assistant to set a reminder, and the
assistant said, "no".
I really do like the music.
I'm sorry.
I get chills just thinking about it.
Yeah so do it.
I don't know what I would do to you if you
ever disobeyed me Google.
Tell me another horror story.
Here are some matching news articles.
What?
No.
I don't want news articles.
That's not what I asked for.
Sorry, I'll try to do better.
Darn right you will.
Alright, let's see if we can get another one.
Tell me a scary story.
Have you heard the urban legend about the
power cord that was too short?
About 10 years ago, there was this guy.
I think his name was Henry, anyway, he bought
an alarm clock to put on his nightstand, but
when he tried to plug it in, it was just too
short.
That's it?
I hope that one doesn't give you nightmares.
I mean in a way it kind of does.
I rely on the Google Assistant as my alarm
clock.
I do sometimes think, what if the phone were
to die or something, what if the battery were
to die when I have something important going
on?
I do like the narration though, I think this
AI does a better job of narrating than some
conscious narrators.
I don't think that one's gonna give me nightmares
though.
Let's try this.
Tell me your scariest story.
Did you hear the urban legend about the water
spiller of '96?
So I have a friend who has this uncle that
knows a guy that was there when this happened.
Apparently, some maniac went rogue in a Circuit
City and started spilling water on all of
the electronics.
It was a massacre.
The scary part is... they're still out there.
That's kind of funny because this phone is
the first one I've gotten that's water resistant,
and I think most of the phones on the market
now are water resistant.
But yeah, in '96 that would be pretty terrifying.
Let's see if Google's got any more.
They usually want stories that are around
10 minutes, so do you have anything like that?
I can search the web for answers.
No, I don't want the web's help, I want your
help.
Here are some results from a search.
And you give me the web's help.
Wonderful.
Tell me another scary story.
Have you ever heard the urban legend about
the assistant...
You already told me this one.
You already told me this story.
Here is a matching video.
No, I didn't say Eddie told me this story.
Tell me a new horror story.
Here are some matching news articles.
What?
No.
Tell me a scary story I haven't heard.
Have you heard the urban legend about the
power cord that was too short?
Let's get creepy.
Let's talk about something else.
What?
Oh man.
They must know I'm filming a YouTube video,
and they're like, "oh no, advertisers aren't
gonna like creepy."
Let's get spooky.
Let the haunting begin.
Ooh, there we go!
Uh oh.
So when I tell it to get spooky, it just starts
playing Halloween sounds.
I mean, you can see it.
Problem is I don't know if these are royalty
free sounds.
Stop playing music.
What's your favorite horror movie?
Movies frequently mentioned on the web include:
Halloween, The Exorcist, The Shining and others.
The Shining is my favorite horror movie so
that's off to a pretty good start with this
list.
Psycho is also one of my favorites.
The Evil Dead.
This is a pretty good list.
Scream.
Alien.
The Thing.
I approve of Google's list of favorite horror
movies.
There's some good stuff on there.
Tell me something creepy.
Catnipsom says that a typical cat sleeps for
2/3 of it's life sleeping.
That means by the time a cat is 9, it's only
been awake for 3 years.
How is that creepy?
What?
What is this?
OK?
Oh, this is a V-Sauce video.
I can't watch this.
That's funny though.
Tell me something scary.
Did you hear--
No, you already told me this story!
Just tell me a story.
It was a dark and stormy night.
A scream rang out from the blackness.
"Happy Birthday" shouted the Google Assistant
as the lights came on.
OK...
It's not my birthday.
I got mixed up.
You should keep the cake though.
Where's the cake?
I found a few locations.
You need more stories, Google.
This looks cool, mind tricks.
Pick any number between 1 and 20.
No, I hate these things.
What are you gonna be for Halloween?
I still can't decide.
Good thing I have a quiz that can help.
What should I be for Halloween.
Let's do that.
Wow, I'm so glad you asked.
I don't want to toot my own horn, but I'm
kind of an expert.
Oh, hold on.
Wait what?
Trick or treat!
Nice costumes.
Who's trick-or-treating at Google's house
in February?
OK, run along and have fun.
Thank you!
I need to help someone now.
Bye.
OK.
Let me access your costume interests with
a few questions.
Do you regularly yell for other people to
bring you things?
I mean, does Uber Eats count?
That didn't seem like an answer.
I'm just gonna put no.
Freaky answer!
Freaky!
Is it OK to read over an unsuspecting person's
shoulder?
Yeah why not?
Freak answer.
Now try this one.
Again.
Do you change your toothbrush every few months?
No.
Like I change the brush head, but I don't
change the toothbrush because it's an electric
toothbrush.
Would you risk severe bruising just to make
a grumpy baby laugh?
Bruising on me or bruising on the baby?
I'm just gonna say Yes.
That's a very telling answer.
One last question.
It's a big one.
Pretend that you work for a really demanding
boss.
And he asks you to get him a brain--
Oh that's so cool!
--it's for an important project--
I would totally be that boss.
--before an electrical storm rolls into town.
You heard there might be a damaged brain available
at the local brain depository.
What do you do?
Get the brain.
You gotta get the brain!
Awesome, thanks.
Let me make a few quick calculations.
Alright.
Special delivery for Halloween.
It's your head!
In a box.
That's the costume!
Head in a box.
That's the costume?
Do you want to take the quiz again?
I don't want to take the quiz again.
Ok, so the costume is basically that thing
from Se7en.
OK.
You know what.
Self destruct.
Self-destructing in 3, 2, 1.
Actually I think I'll stick around.
OK.
Um.
Oh here's a good one.
Open the pod bay doors.
I can't do that.
But there's a spare key under the flowerpot
outside the pod bay airlock.
You can let yourself in.
Nice.
Alright, well I think we got all of the creepy
stuff that we're gonna get out of Google Assistant.
I guess I just have one last thing to ask
it then.
OK Google.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.
When do you want to be reminded?
No.
No...
That's not what-- I was doing the outro.